so have you all completed your sign
up on learn
yes okay that's great and i see a lot
many new participants as well today
so i'll uh take you through how you can
sign up on learn and get access to
the uh asynchronous material
asynchronous asynchronous course
material
and leverage uh all the benefits
now i see ali ali ahazan you are from a
research fellowship program have you
completed your profile
you can unmute yourself
hi mithali are you from india
yes ma'am i'm from india
that's great what are you pursuing right
now
i am doing msc biochemistry in rewa
university
okay you are from river university and
which here are you right
um
[Music]
okay and what are your research
interests
uh mama um
just someone suggested me uh today is my
first uh
uh i think today is my first class mom
okay do you want to learn so
yeah yeah it's good to have you do you
know dr ramesh from
uh from your department yeah yeah yes
okay so we have had a data science
program for one month
for your seniors perhaps second year
students
so many i think 50 people or plus 60
people
did that course and also have interns
from your university who are working
we're working with ashrayashi and
shriyoshi
um i think if you know them
all right thank you uh for uh joining
today's meeting
and we'll be starting in a minute or so
and yeah over to you sonalika
we can't hear you sorry
sonalika
sonalika you're muted can you see us
uh but yes actually i'm joined uh from
another uh device with my mic on can you
hear me
now we can hear you can you start over
again we can't
see you either okay fine actually i'm
painted from two systems right now
because it's an
issue so yes just give me a
second so i was saying that we have a
lot many new participants as well today
and that's why i would be introducing
ourselves first and then we'll take over
the presentations
for today's research fellowship meeting
introducing myself
i am sonalika ray and i'm the omixlogic
community manager
and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users
that are a part of a bioinformatics
community which is managed by
pine biotech introducing our company
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10
000 users around the world and due to
this fast growth our team is working
with local and regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources
as well adapting them to the needs of
students
and researchers around the world so for
those joining for the first time
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
talk about the bioinformatics research
fellowship
program
yes i'm so sorry
talking about the bioinformatics
research fellowship program it is a very
structured program that
guides students through various areas of
big data bioinformatics research
using practical examples and during this
program we would go through several high
quality research publications
and learn about applications of
computational biology in projects
and these publications describe and this
kind of
an experience allows beginners to try
computational biology
techniques on public domain data making
it possible to work with large files
and extract meaningful information from
patient samples animal models
cell lines and microbiota our training
is designed to allow participants to
apply
methods to curated and new data sets and
develop
independent projects that showcase what
has been learnt in the context of a
personal portfolio of projects
and as a result anyone starting on the
journey in bioinformatics
can start developing a project of their
own
in fact we have already worked with many
students who have completed this kind of
training
and developed interesting research
projects that won awards and got
published in peer-reviewed journals
so before we begin with uh today's
research fellowship presentations let us
quickly
go to learn.org logic as i can see we
have a lot many
new participants today so those who are
new here i would uh want them to go to
learn.oxlogic let me know once you are
here i am sending the link in the chat
box
once you visit learn.org portal you need
to sign up on the portal
and you can do so with either your uh
by creating your id and password or by
log signing up with any of your social
accounts
those who have joined the meeting for
the first time once you are signed up
please let me know in the chat box by
sending either one or yes so that i know
you have signed up
signing off maybe someone could also
clarify for those that are signing up
and especially i want to make this clear
for those that are a part of the lbrn
program
we need your id once you sign up
so let me share with you what is the id
maybe somebody can i share my screen
yeah sure
okay okay so
once you sign up so again if you're
not signed up yet you can go to log in
and on the login screen there will be an
option to sign up
okay actually i'm going to stop sharing
okay so what we need for our records uh
the
the reason that we are doing this
specifically for the lbrn is because you
have a
scholarship from lbrn so right here you
will have create an account
and somebody could please face this link
directly in the chat for to sign up
so once you create an account and you
log in let me just briefly log
in here what we need from you
is the link to your profile and that is
a specific code
you can get that code by clicking right
here
on your name and this right here on top
is the full url that's what we need so
please send that to us
either paste it in the chat or
you can send it to us by email
okay that's an example
so you can go ahead sonic
thank you so much elia uh
so uh we have uh wait a second
yes hi ali can you
i would want uh the participants to mute
themselves i
can't see who's unhurting yes thank you
so much
uh hi ali so starting with you uh we
we would want to know about your
research uh progress
hello ma'am good evening good evening
i was very sick i was infected with it
that's why i didn't do that much
progress in my study
i think i need more time in this week
i assure you i will
i will not disappoint you right right no
no no issues at all thank you ali yes uh
now i would want dr harpreet to please
uh introduce herself to the new
participants we have
for the research fellowship program and
then we may proceed with the
presentations over to you dr harpreet
thank you sonalika let me just share my
screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
but before uh my phd i have done my
masters in molecular biology and
biochemistry
after doing my masters i was always
interested in learning
like how these molecular mechanisms
playing important role in different
disease conditions
ah and besides i also know that there is
continuously
enormous unjust data is generated by
number of the research lab for thousands
of the patients
so i believe one can analyze such data
to understand what are the biological
and molecular processes
that are taking place under underlying
specific disease condition
so i have then i have joined phd in
bioinformatics at csir institute of
microbial technology chandigarh in india
under the professor gps raghva's lab
so my phd work on biomarker discovery
for liver cancer so during my phd
so during my phd first why
i chosen this topic so it is well known
that
liver cancer is one of the major lethal
malignancy
which is considered as third major
labor malignancy in terms of mortality
by sixth
in terms of number of incidents so then
i went through the literature to
understand what are the challenges
that are associated with the liver
cancer so
during this my literature review process
i have find there is a need to identify
important signature
that can predict liver cancer
at an early stage and there is still
need
another factor that contributes to the
poor prognosis of the liver cancer that
is tumor reoccurring
so based on my literature review process
i understand that there is a major
concern that needs to be addressed that
is
first is can accurate cancer prediction
particularly for the liver cancer both
hepatocellular carcinoma and
chlangiocarcinoma
second is its diagnosis at an early
stage then there is a need to
identify important signature that can
stratify hcc patients into
low and high risk spaces
so based on this literature background
first we generated
a resource that is cancer level
where we compile the data associated
with nearly 600 biomarkers
to understand what are the major
limitation associated
with already already known signatures
and the biomarker
in the second part of this cancer level
resource we also
compile the data for nearly 10 000 liver
cancer patients from different public
repositories so that we can
address those concerns so
in the next project we have come
extracted the data from different public
repository
including geo and tcca for nearly
4 000 patients to identify
a robust diagnostic biomarker that can
predict
hepatocellular carcinoma with maxima
accuracy so in the subsequent project
here we have extracted the data
from the tcga for nearly 350
patients and here we have tried to
identify
signatures based on transcriptomics and
epigenomics data
that can classify early in the latest
liver cancer samples with nearly
accuracy
80 percent so then we focused on the
next malignancy for the liver cancer
that is chlangiocarcinoma
so to identify robust transcriptomic
signature for the phalangeal carcinoma
we have again extracted the data from
the geo
and other public repositories for the
clangio carcinoma
so here we have extracted nearly 600
samples
and then we have tried to identify
important signature based on the three
genes
that can predict chlangiocarcinoma
uh or classify chlangiocarcinoma from
hcc in the normal sample
with nearly 90 percent accuracy
so then eventually based on all my ps
during my phd work
first we have identified three gene
based signature that can predict
hcc from the normal sample with
more than 90 percent accuracy and in the
second part
we have identified three gene based
signatures that is lamb c2
uh itc and c2 that can discriminate
clangio carcinoma for normal and that cc
sample with nearly 90
accuracy and in the next part we have
identified 51
features that include 30 rna transcript
and 21
methylation cpd sites that can classify
at least t samples from the latest
sample with nearly 80 percent accuracy
in the last part we also try to predict
uh some
uh signatures that can pre uh that can
stratify
a low and high risk
uh reoccurrence groups of the scc
patients
so apart from that uh during my doctoral
research project
i have commander uh four research
though who are actually uh mtech
students
and um in one of the project we have
created a resource
that is rare lsd which uh which is a
manually created database for the
lysosomal enzyme
associated with the real disease and in
the second part we have created
a database for the biomarkers for the
prostate cancer
and both of these works get published
and two uh two other works are still in
communication
so apart from that when i joined fine
bar tech
here we i have mentioned number of the
research follows
so the first we have semi dorana
who is undergraduate student at turkey
and
her work is already published where she
have worked on identifying the long
non-coding rna as therapeutic target
and in chronic lymphocytic leukemia
and she's she have used the publicly
available data
for the uh cll cancer and she
implemented various bioinformatics tools
that are integrated on t1 for server
in the another project she's also
completed her research project
entitled in silico analysis of
characterization of differentially
expression to distinguish
gliomas stem cells from the neural
normal neural stem cells using publicly
available data from the
sr ncbi itself by implementing various
in silico tools that are integrated on t
band for server
so then we have uh we have mr kalamari
who is a phd student
uh at mexico and he's he has worked on a
project
classification of triple negative breast
cancer cell line
by gene expression analysis of
transmembrane protein implementing
machine learning techniques
apart from them then we have de lara de
caine
so who worked on metagenomics project
entitled
radiation 3 3 to the human in space and
alternative approach with the
probio probiotics
so apart from graduate and postgraduate
students
then we have high school student and one
of them is nitra siri reversion
who worked on a research project
entitled effect of the onset of
menopause on the transcriptomic
profile of the easing females and she
has also taken the data from the public
repository
that is uh geo and she implemented
various bioinformatics tools
to identify important transcriptomic
signatures
then we have another uh high school
student
mr anders i'm sosa so he worked as
he also worked on alzheimer's uh
alzheimer's disease
where he used publicly available data to
identify
a moiled beta induced neutrophil
activation
that may provide a link between two
pathological harmonics for the
alzheimer's disease so i'm looking
forward
being your mentor so thank you everyone
thank you dr harpreet and uh thank you
everyone again for joining so
let me uh kind of pick it up from where
uh doctor
pre finished she mentioned some of these
projects
and as you can see the projects come
from very different backgrounds some
people
are from high school level some people
are from undergraduate or even graduate
phd students
and i think that's what's important
about this program today in the session
you can see
the diverse uh backgrounds of everybody
who's participating we have here people
that are from
around the world and all that connects
us
is this i think passion for research
and our interest in bioinformatics but
also there are many differences right so
there's many different interests
and many different directions that you
will be taking throughout your
research fellowship so uh let me briefly
describe
how this research fellowship is going to
work
the place to start is to complete your
profile
really that is where you're going to
have all of the information
about you so that we can see it your
mentor can see it and others will see
when they look at your um
at your project so again where is your
profile
your profile is if you click right here
and what's important is to have a
profile
picture and social media links because
we want to know not just who you are but
also connect with you and we want to
encourage this networking between the
research fellows as well
so typically your professional profile
is going to be on linkedin
maybe your research profile is going to
be
right here on work id
and others and you can also write a
brief description about yourself you can
edit all of this information right here
now then down below you will see some
points
these are very important points that we
can keep track of your progress but also
you can know
where you are and how consistent you are
in your learning
so as you join the research fellowship
start by looking at existing materials
that we have here
that will give you a sense of the
different types of data that you can
work with
how to find this data some project
examples that you can
reference in your study etc
then you will have right here your
subscription so all of you that are
already a part of the research
fellowship should have
a starter subscription that gives you
access to all the previous
premium materials on the portal if you
don't have this
please do let us know the easiest would
be to let us know right now
if you don't see that you just write it
in chat and we will check it for you and
make sure that you have it before the
end of the session
also you will find down below some
badges
and these badges correlate to the
different programs that we have
these programs include training on data
science infectious diseases precision
medicine source growth 2
and others and so if you want to learn
about these you can explore
the different types of programs that we
have by going right here
on the programs tab and finding here a
mentor guided program that is most
suitable for you
okay so nalika please take a look yoshi
get war is saying that she doesn't see
the start of subscription so
we need to fix that i usually if you can
please
post the url to your profile that will
help us
find you quickly okay so what is the url
to your profile
right here that full url is what you
need to put in the chat
does anyone else have any issues with
their subscription
thank you okay so we can go to this
profile
so again please try to keep your profile
with the full name as you would like it
to
appear on your certificate
okay so eliminate this zero one
please have a full name please add your
picture
social media links in a brief intro and
we will make sure that we have your
information updated and give you the
full subscription
so nanik it also looks like graphic
bamra
does not have the full subscription
either
oh so i would like to
okay i'm so sorry for this yes so i
would like to uh
tell you that to get the access to a
start content
you need to uh take the basic
subscription
that is of dollar ten and when i say
that you can sign up
for free that means that you would have
the access to all the
asynchronous course material that is
present for free
on a portal but all the start content
could be
accessed only with the basic
subscription that you would have to
proceed with i'll
send you the details ayushi and i just
checked uh your subscription is not
active just because you
don't have the basic subscription
activated for yourself
and good prath ayushi please uh please
uh
tell me your mail ids in the chat box
itself i'll need you the details
thank you over to you india thank you
yeah so again
if you uh want to join the research
fellowship you haven't finalized that
yet you can just click right here to
research and you can find the different
options
if you're already a part of lbrn and
your subscription has been supported by
the louisiana biomedical research
network you need to let us know
and especially if you don't have the
subscriptions finalized
okay so now because we do have a lot of
new people
joining today maybe we can hear briefly
about you uh why you're joining the
research fellowship
what you are seeking to gain out of this
experience maybe what is your current
background
so please let me start with abu bakr
abdul qadir
abu bakr if you could please introduce
yourself
hello hello hi
hmm man get a speech um problem again
sorry uh yes abu bakr you can tell us
about yourself in the chat box
uh thank you so much then we have ariana
with us
ariana can
his microphone is working abu bakr are
you able to introduce yourself
uh so india i think abu bakr is trying
to say that he has
uh some speech issue and he can't uh
speak
so he wants to introduce himself in the
chat box
yes uh thank you so
right much i see so he did write before
let's just read that out real quick
so he's saying that he's a phd student
in environmental toxicology at southern
university a
m college baton rouge okay and he's
working on the
immunotoxological effects of some toxics
so if you could add to this information
this is good information abu bakr thank
you
if you could add to this the information
about your the reason why you joined
so what are you seeking to get out of
this program
are you do you have a specific project
that you're planning to work on
do you already have a project in mind a
topic or a research question
and what do you envision
getting out of this three months
fellowship thank you
please go ahead so anika who else do we
have
thank you alia we have ariana with us
today she has recently joined a research
fellowship program
so ariana i would want you to please
introduce yourself first
over to you and also tell us about your
research and trust
and what you are looking forward to over
to you ariana
oh hey um ariana is my daughter she is
uh taking a class now she we are in
arizona
uh phoenix arizona she is a high school
student but she
is a summer class in maricopa community
college
and i'm i i saw that i was just i was
just talking to we were talking to dr
tui in the glendale community college
where i see you guys have taught a class
with him in bioinformatics
last semester so that's where we get a
kind of a connection so ariana has us
taking the bio class right now bio
181 with with the
community college so she she is not able
to join and she asked me to talk to you
guys here
now her interest is
she's doing in the community college
taking some bio classes
at the same time she is doing her
artificial intelligence
program in the community college here
channel at gilbert community college so
she has some
idea she has some background on the
python she's doing some machine learning
courses
and then she is also pursuing the
biology so she has some interest around
that
she's only a 8th grade she's she's only
9th grade
student she has interest in doing some
research
research projects so that she can turn
into a science fair
project through the research so that is
her goal
science fair project now so she hasn't
chosen anything yet she was proud she is
looking for some mentorship
guidance as i said she is a very young
only 14 years old so some guidance would
be very good for her
um we are seeking some help if this is a
possibility
and then when she is very aggressive she
wants to learn more
so whenever there's an opportunity we
wanted to sync up with you guys and see
what is the
what are the options available
especially learning the data sources
and you know and what is the popular
um popular uh thing needs to be
researched in this current moment and
what is uh
pretty popular so that she can turn into
a science fair that is it thank you
uh if you guys have any comments let us
know
i do have a question so i didn't
understand that you're
the father of ariana what is your name
and has ariana already created a profile
i think she did yes yeah i can send it
to you here
i believe she did and but i don't think
she has updated
yeah okay perfect all right
great sounds good yeah so we will try to
find a time that works also for her
we will have we do have a batch of
advanced high school students
in the u.s that are going to be meeting
in the afternoons so maybe that is one
of the
batches that we could include her in uh
that'd be better
yeah sure yeah and then are you guys
offering any class
um anymore like bioinformatics classes
with the glendale community college is
the dr tui
uh in next semester yes i think we're
planning to but
we need to coordinate with him exactly
how that will work and
what are the dates so that that will be
more up to him but i think we're
planning to speak with him later this
week
okay so ariana yeah we are also meeting
him
um tomorrow and going ariana will be in
his lab
so she will be taking some classes under
him um in
and then as a research partner also
probably wanted to credit under him so
that he can have access to the lab
perfect okay
thank you so much sir and thank you so
much
elia now i would uh want our research
fellow rucha kuneti to please present
her research progress
rucha i'm giving you the access to share
your screen
uh well doctor muhammad can you please
give her the access
make up the co-host
okay
thank you um hello can you uh see my
screen
yes yes we can see your screen we can
hear you as well thank you
okay um so today i'll be uh
giving my uh a progress in
my project a transcriptomic analysis of
neurons and oligodendrocytes of the
occipital
lobe in alzheimer's disease so first of
all
let me introduce myself
my name is rucha and i'm from bangalore
india
i'm currently studying biotechnology at
ramayana institute of technology
so i've previously done
[Music]
molecular docking studies on drug
resistant tuberculosis
and sarcophagu but my interest always
was in genetics genomics epigenetics and
transcriptomics and how they can be
used to analyze various diseases so
i'm also interested in learning about uh
you know the various illnesses
that affect the brain like
neurodegenerative diseases
or personality disorders like adhd
bipolar disorders etc
so that's why i chose to do my project
on alzheimer's disease
which is a neurodegenerative disorder
and it affects
individuals of over 60 years of age or
with
or people with trisomy 21
and common symptoms include memory
and in cognitive impairments
and with further disease progression we
have other symptoms like
delusions agitations and mood
disturbances also
and 80 is mostly characterized by the
formation of
uh protein aggregates that is a neurotic
plaques and neurofibrillary tangles
uh these plaques are actually
the beta amyloid peptide aggregates and
the tangles are actually
uh caused due to the hyper
phosphorylation of the tau protein
so you can see here these are the
tangles and these are the plaques
um so
for one second
okay so um so most studies have
established that um
microglia which are the resident
macrophages in the brain
uh these are involved in the ad
pathology and
and the neurons in the limbic regions
that is the hippocampus temporal lobe
and the parietal lobe of the brain
are affected and we know that neurons
are the fundamental units of the cns
so they're involved in impulse
transmission in the body
so uh now research is still being done
to find out if other cells uh and
tissues of the brain are affected
like oligodendrocytes or blood vessels
etc
so now oligodendrocytes are a type of
glial cells
which are non-neuronal cells and they
don't conduct
impulses but they're involved in
homeostasis
and they provide support and protection
to the neurons
so oligodendrocytes in particular they
are involved in
formation of the myelin sheath around
the axons
uh so now what is the occipital lobe
so this region is present at the
posterior region of the brain and
it includes regions like occipital
cortex and occipital temporal cortex
and is involved in visual perception
spatial reasoning
and processes input from other regions
of the brain
so scientists are still researching the
full effects of
uh ad like uh on different parts of the
brain not just the limbic
uh limbic system so that is why
uh yeah so that is why i
chose to do my project on what type of
cells are affected and
in this particular region in alzheimer's
disease
so uh for this project i chose my data
set
from this bio project
uh geo data set which actually analyzed
the microglia profiles in ad so in this
data set
there are cell samples obtained from the
occipital lobe of the brain from three
age match groups there is ad control and
control plus
so the ad samples they have both the
amyloid beta
beta pathology and the turbo anthology
and the control samples have neither
amyloid beta
nor top pathology and control plus
samples
have some level of amyloid pathology but
there's no tau protein aggregation
so and the difference between these uh
control and ad is that ad
brains are uh
they have signature uh dementia while uh
the control samples they are
then they are non-demented brains
so this is the data set
and the total 59 samples
and 26 of them are oligodendrocytes
and 33 are neuronal samples
and these cells are obtained only from
the gray matter region
so
uh so my research questions uh
and hypothesis are uh so we know that
memory and
uh cognitive impairments are the
impairments are the
major symptoms of ads and these
functions are under the control
of the limbic system so
uh our neurons of only these regions
being affected or
neurons of other brain regions are also
being affected
in the same way in ad that's my question
and and also uh in addition uh
like what other cells are being affected
like
oligodendrocytes and again
oligodendrocytes of
the occipital lobe in this case and if
so
what genes are being upregulated or
downregulated
in the affected cells and what are the
pathways
and biological functions being
compromised
due to ad in these cells
so i first did a principal component
analysis
uh for the cell samples and you can see
this is pc
one versus pc3 and these
red clusters are neuronal samples and
the blue ones are the oligodendrocytes
so uh this contributes to a total of 70
variants in the whole data set
so then i did a differential gene
expression analysis of
8481 genes using dc2
and uh with a p p
p value of less than or zero uh sorry p
value less than or equal to 0.05 uh
so i did four types of dg analysis
uh two for neurons and two for
oligodendrocytes
and uh this these are the results i got
so
in the neuronal cell sample uh
in 80 versus ctr i got 34 differentially
expressed genes
and in 80 versus control plus i got 168
differentially expressed genes similarly
in oligodendrocytes i got
a 399 for 80 versus ctr and 56 for 80
versus control plus
so today i'll be uh talking about uh
these results in particular so
in a the differentially expressed
genes of the neurons so i annotated them
according to
gene ontology and found that there were
no
major role in played by these
genes in ad-related changes so which
probably explains why this pca looks
like this
uh the all the samples are like are
present together
they don't form uh separate clusters so
that's
probably why and this is the same
neuronal samples just uh the groups have
been separated this is
adverse ctr and this is a d versus
ctr plus you can see that there's no
clear cluster formation
coming to oligodendrocytes uh i again
did the same thing
i annotated them according to gene
ontology
and found that many of the genes were
playing a role in
ad progression so you can see here uh
the clusters are a bit more clear
these are the 80 samples and these are
the control
the control plus is kind of present in
between probably because
they have characteristics of both like
um they are similar to control
uh as their non-demented brains and
they're also similar to the ad samples
because they have
the amyloid beta plaques so going
further into the oligodendrocytes
this is the same thing the pca for 80
versus ctr and ade versus control plus
there's a clear cluster formation here
so
going further for the oligodendrocytes
uh
first i'll be talking about the 80
versus control plus
so here among the upregulated genes i
found
gli 3 which
is actually involved in
the wnt pathway and causes
its negative regulation which
contributes to
the loss of impulse conduction in ad
patients
so wnt pathway is actually a
impulse conduction pathway broadly
speaking and this is very important
in maintaining the synaptic
plasticity in the adult brains and among
the down regulated genes in this group i
found there are a lot of mitochondrial
genes being down regulated
which cause the disruption in the
electron transport system
leading to oxidative stress which
actually uh
further induces uh the amyloid beta
growth in the cells
so this is a volcano plot of
oligodendrocytes ad versus ctr
and you can see the mitochondrial genes
being
downregulated here and
next is 80 versus ctr so
here i found some genes like a protein
kinase
genes for encoding protein kinases like
ak
ak5 and prgk1 being upregulated
so these kinases are actually involved
in
a phosphorylating proteins and are
involved in microtubule formation
so ak5 is pretty important in
maintaining the microtubule structure
so since it's being upregulated it
actually
hyperphosphorylates the top protein
the top protein is actually
required for a proper microtubule
formation
and if it gets
phosphorylated uh to a greater extent it
can negatively
uh regulate the empty assembly
which is actually what happens in the
ad patients and that's why microtubules
are very weak in
ad patients so you can see here
ak5 is being upregulated this is a
volcano plot for ad versus ctr
oligodendrocyte samples
uh next uh coming to the
down regulated genes in 80 versus ctr
i found these two genes being down
regulated
that is bace2 and apc2
so apc2 is a wnt signaling pathway
regulator
and is also involved in the microtubule
formation
so like i said it's very uh the wnt
signaling pathway is pretty important
for maintaining
synaptic plasticity uh in the adult
brain
so since it's being down regulated
that is why we have a synapse
dysfunction in
80 patients and bace 2
is a beta secretase 2 enzyme
which is actually homologous to the main
beta secretary's enzyme bac1
now uh bac1 is what actually causes the
uh amyloid beta progression in ad
patients
uh it happens when the ace one gets
upregulated
so and at the same time uh
bace2 is uh being down regulated
uh so that's what adds to the
amyloid beta uh progression so bac2
actually in healthy individuals is
expressed in
relatively lower concentrations but it
does play a pretty
important role in delaying ad
progression
this is because it cleaves the app which
is actually
which is nothing but the amyloid
recursive protein
uh and as the name says it's the
precursor protein for the amyloid beta
aggregates so it cleaves app
at a particular site different from the
ac
one side and that's how it prevents the
amyloid beta
uh progression so since it's being down
regulated here
uh it's probably why uh the amyloid beta
plaques progress in ad
in addition to the up regulation of the
ace one
so and these are some of the uh enriched
pathways
i found when i did a dc to analysis
so you can see here in neurons uh
you can see here there's not much uh of
genes involved in ad progression whereas
here you can
see a lot of mitochondrial
functions being suppressed in the
oligodendrocytes ad versus control plus
and here in the neurons again you don't
see
any much of ad-related changes
whereas here you can see a lot of
nerve impulse uh conduction and
neurotransmitter
activity being suppressed so from this
uh it seems that neurons
are not as affected as uh
neurons of the limbic system uh as one
would have thought
like you you think uh neurons of
all the brain regions would be affected
but this is not so
so in the occipital lobe neurons seem
relatively unaffected compared to the
oligodendrocytes
so with this i end uh
today's presentation and um
after this i thought i could do some
pathway analysis like why this
difference is seen why neurons are
relatively unaffected than the
oligodendrocytes which i thought i'll do
in the coming week so um thank you
everyone for listening
thank you so much rocha for such a
wonderful presentation
uh i would want dr harpreet uh to please
give the suggestions now
okay so uh i mean you did a lot of
analysis but
somewhere you're in you need to
interpret it a better way
so can you just go to the your uh
volcano plots
actually you are uh just i mean
confusing here uh
yourself here okay so can you just show
the plot here
so actually the gene that uh can you
tell me like
based on the log to four chains which um
which genes can be considered as
upregulated and which genes can be
considered as downregulated
uh it's the log to fall change positive
values are
upregulated but uh negative values are
down regulated
exactly now can you look at your plot
volcano plot
oh yes
yeah these genes are upper regulated
that are present on
right side and the genes that are
present on the left side because here
minus four minus two right yes
i understand that but uh i'm yeah but
maybe you are talking about
in terms of when you actually decide
your groups group one and group two if
you remember
when you were younger from that
perspective you have to
mention like that actually that is why
i'm saying you are
uh interpreting i mean you are doing in
wrong interpretation in terms of up
regulation or the down regulation
because then you are talking about in
terms of
which group you are talking about right
you have to yes
so based on this like uh the positive
log to four chains means these are
upregulated genes while negative four
chains means these are uh down regulated
gene so this is something you need to
correct
and uh one one second mom um that is
true
in case of uh control plus i was talking
in terms of a d
mom yeah i mean then you have to mention
exact group when okay
yeah i forgot to mention yes i'm sorry
i'm sorry you have to write uh because
we are looking at this result so based
on this result we are going to integrate
so you have to mention in which context
you are talking about right okay okay
i'm sorry i forgot to mention that yes
ma'am because based on this plot
you can say that this particular genes
are upregulated in whatever the
condition i mean you have to mention
that condition here
okay okay yes okay
so now i will uh ask india to uh
if he give you some suggestions
um yeah thank you it was very
interesting to hear the presentation as
far as i understood
your main question is
development of alzheimer's disease or
really the manifestation of clinical
symptoms
of alzheimer's disease in specific types
of
cells neurons versus oligo
uh whatever they're called all
dendrocytes yeah yes yes and so
you're trying to ask this question
and uh you know my question would be
is this really a question that has not
been answered yet is there
literature examples that show that this
is
a very important topic to study it has
not
been studied before yeah i searched a
lot about this and
uh there are more mostly research
articles
only based on the neurons of the limbic
system
so other cells uh there's not much
research done at
all yet so it's still going on
okay doing doing a search uh
i do see some articles that speak about
this
um early oligodendrocyte
myelin pathology and alzheimer's
generation of human neurons
and oligodendrocytes
neuro oligodendrocyte interactions
right so it seems like there has been
some research already done on this yeah
but
it's very less compared to the actual
what
people are finding so you're saying that
you're so that's what i think you should
make clear in your specific objectives
is how what you are proposing to do or
what you're already doing
how is that going to address some of
these gaps in research that you see
okay okay and also what is the utility
so let's say you understand this let's
say you get to the bottom
of activated pathways specifically
in oligodendrocytes yeah
how is this important what are we going
to do with this information
um the fact that some of these uh
neurons were
unaffected but these oligodendrocytes
were affected maybe there's some
uh pathways being uh
like you know some channels like uh
cation channels or something being
affected so maybe
that's what's protecting those neurons
and uh
analyzing those particular pathways can
help us like
find ways to protect all the other cells
okay so maybe you should refine that
idea also
what exactly is the um
you know it's so have you ever looked at
cell
morphology what they look like
what neurons look like yeah well both of
these
i think if you go back you had a slide
right yeah yeah it's
here these are neurons and this is
oligodendrocytes
so i mean we can see that they're
already very different right
yeah and because they're very different
we are expecting them to have
differences
even in healthy tissue right yes yes
that's true and from what i've seen
i have not seen a comparison between
alzheimer's
so if you have a sense of difference
between oligodendrocytes
in alzheimer's disease and
non-alzheimer's disease
as well as neuron cells and alzheimer's
versus non-alzheimer's
you could have then a comparison of
differentially expressed genes
in alzheimer's between oligodendrocytes
and neurons right okay yeah
and that could be an interesting
question if that's really the focus of
your study
you could then see whether there are
specific genes or even pathways
and what does that mean and so as a
result
actually you can turn this whole study
into kind of the next level which is to
do
a classification of four different
groups
so you have oligodendrocytes alzheimer's
non-alzheimer's neurons alzheimer's
non-alzheimer's
so you have four classes so it would be
interesting
to do classification and feature
selection to extract specific genes that
could help you identify
what are the you know what are the
markers
of these conditions and when you have
that
there is a single cell atlas of
alzheimer's disease
okay where you could just look up those
genes and that would be a
cross-reference or kind of a
you know validation study that you could
do to check whether
you find those genes and they are
regulated in a specific way
in different tissues
okay
so um to do a feature selection for
all the four groups is that what you're
saying
yeah okay how many total number of
samples do you have again
i think you have 59. total
it's uh 59. so maybe it's not enough
in this study but yeah
it's also considering only the gray
matter area so
so maybe but you can still think about
it i think that would be a useful
approach because
if you do differential gene expression
between many to many groups
you will get some genes and the typical
way to then check those
genes is to find another data set and so
maybe you can take a look at
if you have maybe over 100 samples
you could do something uh with
classification and feature selection
that will give you
some sense of you know what is the
utility of this i think the utility
in terms of basic biology if you're
trying to understand activated pathways
you need to then take that you know into
the lab
and and start looking at whether you can
do something with that
as opposed to a classification approach
the classification approach can give you
some markers
and those markers could help you
identify for example in mouse tissue
right and brain
in human tissue maybe that's not
possible but in mouse tissue
you could ask whether those genes have
some variation
in age whether they have some variation
with inflammation caused by other
factors not related to age
right so there's some additional
questions that could make your study
objective more clear because right now
it sounds like
you are investigating this to understand
the biology
but i don't think that necessarily
translates to protection if you identify
those pathways
or if if it does then i think we need to
clarify
how can that be you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah uh okay
um so i thought of finding the reason
why
it's happening like this and then seeing
is that okay
well yeah maybe you should definitely
start with literature review
go back and see what are people saying
about
why these kinds of studies need to be
done and what are the unanswered
questions
specifically and why it is important to
answer these questions and then from all
the possible ideas that you get from
literature if you select
one focus for you and then from there
decide whether what you are currently
doing is sufficient for you to get some
activated pathways what are you going to
do with that information
and if you have specific genes what you
know if you have
let's say 500 differentially expressed
genes
it's not very useful to look at just 500
genes right so you need a smaller number
and the smaller number means that you
have to put the 500 genes into some
context for example
you can do network analysis and identify
key genes
you can do classification to extract
genes that are very specific
and help you discriminate between the
different classes
then you might look for those in maybe
blood
and maybe there's some circulating
biomarkers for detection
that you could find right so there's a
lot of them downstream questions that we
need to refine as well
but you know i i don't want to take away
from the significance of what you
already did i think it's an
excellent way to get started and get
into the topic you already have a lot of
results
it's a useful starting point maybe with
just more clarification
it's a study on its own okay
okay i'll i'll think about it and we'll
do it
perfect thank you thank you thank you
thank you
thank you so much rucha and thank you so
much elia now
i would want uh our research fellow to
please share his progress
over to you today
so mom
due to bandwidth issues i won't be able
to turn on the video
and if it's if it's alright with
everyone
can i start the ppt yes yes you can it's
perfectly fine thank you
is the screen visible if i can ask
anyone
uh yes whether your screen is visible
all right okay so thank you everyone
first of all
who are president here in the meeting
i'm with it i have been a
research fellow with fine biotech and
my research is going to be on a topic
that is of concern
for many of the people in this world and
that is prostate cancer
now uh the prostate cancer disease it's
it's a very
common disease and it's found
mostly in aged males and most of the
times
uh from the literature that i found out
that the common thing that was present
is that was
mostly found in african-american males
and
variations so this is how i started to
develop interest in this topic
and the the
tools available from bind biotech really
helped me to analyze this i'm still on
the very preliminary step
but this is what i uh did and
just to show you and present what i did
in my topic
so what we first understood was about
rna sake and nga sequencing what it
really is
so when we talk about transcriptomics we
did a course on it and
it was very very uh exhaustive and very
interesting to understand what
transcriptomics is having no background
of this
topic and this subject
so we understood what finally
transcriptomics is
uh what transistor transcriptome is and
we
understood all the bases of it from rna
sequencing to mg sequencing how the
sequencing developed
uh finally we understood that what the
gene expression studies were and how
total rna was cut then segmented
uh analyzed using the reference genome
then plotted
and then understood
so when we understood about next
generation sequencing about all the
things that negotiation sequencing did
with
isoforms generation and alternate
splicing everything
related to it when a library was created
so uh when we did this we understood
more about
short rate sequencing lawn breeds that
were available
as you can see in the slide it says that
short sleeve sequencing is actually
cheaper
and which is very big advantage in the
real world when we have to apply
it in the economies which are not really
not really very well
done into research and development for
genomics
and we can see that long reads are
facilitate
the analysis of challenging genomes that
are not
being studied yet and
these genomes with a high percentage of
repetitive
elements can be studied using the long
range so this is what we finally
understood and
we understood that what actually uh next
initial sequencing can really help us in
when we understood this fact from uh we
came a long
way from northern blotting and rt pcr to
finally come to this point
and microarray to finally reach this
point where we
can actually sequence entire genomes
so moving on uh these are the basic and
broad steps of how rna
sequencing works so first of all is the
preprocessing steps that takes place
in uh rna sex and
we we understand that these are first
utilized using the fast and fast queue
formats which are this formats in which
the the genomic uh
data is prescribed into then we align
these reads
we map them into reference you know and
finally calculating the abundance of the
reads
along the reference you know which tells
us how how much and what is the q score
loss associated with it finally and the
last
process of the step would be through
statistically and biological
interpretation of the explanation table
and this is what we are this is what our
end goal is
in this project as well to understand
prostate cancer and the expression
levels of different biomarkers and
prostate cancer
so this is what our final result is
going to be
and so moving on
we have this first step of
pre-processing the data
so first of all uh using pre-processing
it's it can help us eliminate and
moderate technical artifacts such as the
adopters that were present
and sequencing adopters are cleaned from
the reeds
and on the t by info platform there are
five algorithms that are present for
uh pre-processing that is clean primer
added to faster pcr clean
pneumatic that is the one we used and
then there was
gta edges error correction can be
can be done with the help of aimer coral
echo and racer and these are also
available
about 75 of all sequencing errors can be
corrected through
these algorithms and this is the most
important part
because if the basis are not correct
then then it's going to be a very tough
job for everyone to analyze it
so finally uh the sequencing adopters
they need to be cleaned from the reads
and the raw read
data needs to be converted into format
that can be
efficiently used uh for for the
subsequent
algorithms to work on and then we come
to the second step that
would be to mark it and the map on
reference genome
so the raw transatomic rates
are aligned on the genome sequence
for the same more similar species and on
on this reference genome
this helps us to actually quantify the
rates
associated with the experience so when
we
talk about this mapping we have
many algorithms that are present on the
t by input platform that are top hat
bow tie and we can also do isoform
construction using cufflinks
and the slice variants are generated
using the information grade
alignment with the axons and introns
yielded
from the above top hat and high set
that were already present so this is
what we do in
we we did on mapping and reference you
know and we understood about
it the next step would be to calculate
the abundance of rates
now from what i understood is was that
there are two
main formulas that are uh present first
is
actually the rates that are uh read
count that are present
and the next evolved formulas are the
fpgam and the rpk values
both of those have been elaborated in
the slide
the rpg stands for reads per kilo base
of transcripts per million map
trees and fpk would go for them
fragments
per kilo base of transcript per million
map breeds
and so these are the two
things that the two statistical analysis
which tells us the abundance of reach
and uh
it is fpgame is uh used for
paired edge sequencing and rfp game is
used for single in sequencing this is
what we came to know
finally when we understood the
difference between the spk and our
became
uh we got to understand understand that
it is an attempt to measure the absolute
expression level
so and finally we we could differentiate
it from the read counts because
it it it is something that both fpgame
rpkm are far from read count because
uh recounts they need to be normalized
and
fpk and rpk values because in rate
counts there are effects of gene length
and sequencing their data present
so the longer the gene the more uh more
hits it may get
so in order to remove that it needs to
be normalized so that is why fbkm and
rbk values are the two
uh things that we get so finally the
final step that comes in the rna
pipeline would be renew removal of all
the genomic data
that is without expiration that is
present so
um in in this the correction of the
matter would be to disapprove the null
hypothesis that is present
and and to remove the type 1 errors that
we could have the second step would be
to have a quantity normalization and
normalization process
to take place so it's it's a technique
in which we map the original values
of the corresponding quantile of a
standard
distribution uh an estimation of
sequence
depth and experiment is determined by
the upper quantile of the counts
so this is what we understood from it
that comparing the quantile values
instead of the raw values will eliminate
the difference
so we understood that there is a
difference that could
arise from technical variation such as
the amount of rna that was sequenced
or sequencing of machine type and some
unexplained differences as well but
quantity
normalization is used to remove all of
that and finally
we also understood that there are
we can also use the log values to to use
and transcribe it these quantize
normalized values
it is much easier in approach and gives
much better results
when we use log values and finally we
came
across the machine learning approaches
that were the pc analysis and factor
regression analysis
particularly talking about the pc
analysis because it's a very important
subject for anyone who is trying to do
this
uh it it's going to tell you something
very preliminary and it's going to be
very
intriguing for you if you are doing pc
for the very first time
so pca analysis is something that
compresses the expression data that you
had from
thousands of genes into a single one dot
graph
and if you if you had a look at the t
bio
uh info server there's a very uh
there are many many many
pipelines that you can run for the pc
analysis one is the unsupervised the
second one option
you get is in the utility section uh
so that is how you can run it in a very
simple way in the
using the d by input server so it it
does not
select some characteristics and discard
the others but
instead it constructs new
characteristics based on the whole
transition
transcriptome data set that is that is
that you provide to the system
and then it gives us an accurate summary
of all the variables that are being
studied
so so it tells us what you have done in
a best possible way that it could be
understood and
so that you can get the expiration
values it's basically to explore what
you have just done
so and the result that comes out
is that the genes with the largest
variation between the samples will have
the most influence on the
principal components so you will see
there in in the principle component
analysis that you will receive the
result
in forms of percentage so that
percentage will tell you how much
uh variation is present and the largest
variation can be used to study
ahead study further your data so
bottom line that we understood in pca is
from
always learn that was the samples of
similar gene expression when clustered
together in the pc plot
so this is something that you can look
for when you are doing your preliminary
studies
that the samples that you put in if they
are clustering together then that is
what the pc plot is going to show you
and you can
take your studies ahead with that
and so this is what we understood and
the second one was the factor regression
analysis that
happens so factor regression analysis
was the method
to to perform so that the experimental
designs that include two or more factors
such as environment of time environment
or time uh they can be studied
the results from the factor analysis
allows us to study a number of factors
and their interactions
instead of when we are limited to the
differential expression which only
allows
comparison of at least two experimental
factors so this is how
it really helps us and finally we came
to a point of
biological interpretation i'm still yet
to perform this and do this but
from my understanding what i understood
that we the genes that we
get from the facial analysis we have to
analyze them study them
why are there an outliers present in the
pca plot we
study more about them we use the david
uh
software that is present and
we can use then symbol for finding the
unstable id if your
database has ensemble id so that is the
step
of biological interpretation that
happens to be the last one
and finally coming to
uh why i chose prostate cancer because
the first thing that came to my mind and
in which uh all the mentors also helped
me very much
is that first of all it's an age related
disease
and that's why my grandfather also
suffered with it so that's why i was
very very
keen to understand it uh what are the
things that it holds
and my first question then came with the
age relation of this cancer
why is it that in that particular age or
in some particular age
some biomarkers are some genes are over
expressed which result in this cancer
and further on uh increasing the glycine
store and
making it a very malignant cancer and
of course being the life-threatening
cancer that it is
so from this first of all i did a
database search i used
if i take you to the dataset i did a
database search
and so from the maintenance document
told me to search
from fire browse jio data sites uh i
liked
the fire browse very much and i took the
data set from it
and from i also understood that there's
a plot present in
fire browse itself which tells you about
how your data is
your quality of data and what
visualizations can be made from that
data
uh using the plots available there as
only so
uh from firebrowse i took the datasets
for prostate cancer
adrenocarcinoma prostate cancer and
and i i took the datasets and what i
really wanted to understand
was the age and the relation of age with
the
over experience or genes that were
present and the
identification of clinical markers in
prevalence of prostate cancer engagement
that
is going to be my research question my
preliminary research question
finally when i get through this i want
to understand more about it so all these
factors
i got from the data set are present in
my data set
and what are the factors can be used to
understand the expression levels of
genes
for example rays nectary glacial scoring
phosphate
and the psa values psa values psa is the
test
that is used for detection of prostate
cancer
and that is the preliminary test that is
used for understanding prostate cancer
there are however studies being done
to have much better scaling tests done
than pca
psa test and finally the next step are
going to be
i have got my data set the next question
that i want to ask all of you is
first of all the groups that i should
separate my data sets in
uh the answer that i received today was
two separated into groups of
ages uh separated from 10 years like 50
to 60 years of age how many samples are
present there
then 60 to 70 and 70 to 80. and finally
the next question that i would like to
ask all of you is that should i separate
it into cancer types non-transitive and
what all things that
can be derived from this and what all
studies can be done
and your your respective comments on it
as well
so with that i would like to end this
preliminary presentation and
yes uh this is the pc plot that i got
from my data set
uh this is a very very preliminary
and primary thing that i did with just
about
25 to 30 samples and this is what i
received
um so if you can share the light on this
as well to
help you understand or if you can tell
me about this as well
so this was uh my presentation and thank
you all for being very
patient listening and thank you for
listening to me
over to sun camera thank you so much
for uh explaining your progress in such
a wonderful way
i would want dr harpreed to please uh
guide you with the questions
you have put up over to your doctor
okay so actually yeah i mean it's nice
presentation
okay so because you just have uh
prepared your data so
i mean still you need to exactly uh name
your samples
and name your samples based on their
groups so that you will able to get uh
at least exploratory uh first perform
exploratory data analysis that is pc to
get an idea like
what kind of questions can be addressed
right and
maybe right now you have taken just i
guess 20 to 30 samples just do it with
all all the samples so that you will get
idea like
what kind of pattern within your whole
data so that you can actually
then next you can address your questions
okay so instead of considering and of
course instead of the sample id
you nee also need to define i think i
have also already told you like you need
to insert another group
so another row that is actually
explaining like what are these groups so
then based on those groups just perform
your pca
so then uh based on the exploratory data
analysis then we can understand like
what are the different questions that we
can drive from this
right yes okay okay
okay thank you everybody
thank you so much maybe i can add to
this so one time
one thing that you are doing is
exploration of the data i think in
parallel you should be doing
literature review to see
one the publication that came out
with the prostate cancer repository on
ncbi so or sorry on tcga so
every project that came out on tcga
comes with a paper and that paper
describes
what did they do with that data so
you're looking just at gene expression
data but a lot of the objectives from
tcga
was to understand the integration
between different types of data
they developed some methods some of
those methods are also available on the
platform
but they provide you with a sense of
what did they find what did the experts
in the field
that collected and analyzed this data
come out with
right and that will give you some clear
idea about
some of the things that should be a you
know
a confident way to proceed if you want
to
you know build on what has already been
done the second part of that
are some most current literature um
like on a systematic review a really
up-to-date systematic review or even
just a review paper
that will give you some sense of what
are the open questions
about prostate cancer i know from a
little bit of background that
you know i have in participating in
projects on prostate cancer that there
is a
specific drug resistance issue that
occurs at later stages of prostate
cancer called
gastric resistant prostate cancer cancer
and that's a big topic of research right
now
so when you think about precision
treatment
and therapies that are being developed
now a lot of them are being developed
for the cases that do not respond well
to treatments
and so maybe that's one thing that you
can look into
maybe there's some issue with early
stages where
early detection of that resistance can
guide the clinician to
find an appropriate maybe it's drug
repurposing
if you want to treat cancer but you
don't have any new ideas any new drugs
maybe some existing drugs that are being
used for something else
could be applicable here but you need to
know which patient population
so those are some of the questions that
you know i know are
being explored and you should consider
how does that fit in with what you have
um the other thing that i definitely
agree with dr herbert about
annotating these by some kind of
phenotype
and so what are the phenotypes that you
have you have age
you have maybe ethnicity you have maybe
other treatments
that are already right yeah so all of
these and so the question is
out of all of these what types are
categorical data
like race or ethnicity would be
categories
and one of them could be converted into
continuous data so for example
continuous data could be
survival or they could be
maybe you can turn some treatment into
continuous data or
some kind of numeric data that could be
used in more
big data analysis right where you could
maybe find correlation between different
variables
so i think those are some interesting
questions so when you do this kind of
exploratory analysis
one do literature review together with
data exploration
number two when you explore your data
look at the data itself gene expression
but also look at all of these phenotypes
and identify
what types of variables are these and
what you can do with them
and then finally pca is a good way to
get a sense of what's going on but it's
not the only way
and so another way that i would suggest
and this is something you should include
are some maybe box and whisker plots or
box plots
they tell you the distribution and some
outliers in your data
so maybe and even in pca you could see
it you do have some outliers
why are these outliers there are they
different because they just
you know overall the expression is lower
you will see the median lower
yeah like for example in the one on the
left you definitely have an outlier
right there
right but before just removing that
outlier you also can ask the question
why is it there what's unique about that
sample
now the other thing to consider here is
that all cancer data sets are very
very heterogeneous heterogeneous so they
have a lot of
variability in them because these are
real people you know coming from
different places
being sequenced at different places
right so another i think
uh question that you might ask here is
essentially
like corpreed said you know do i just
look at a subset or do i try to look at
everything and within all of the data
that i have what are some of the major
patterns that i see
so maybe these could be helpful for you
okay so thank you so much
um sir if i could ask and
also
for the people's to be really really
helpful i would
really appreciate sure share the papers
with you
actually that's a really good point we
do have
a new course that we're going to publish
either today or tomorrow and that's
going to be all about the project stages
and one of those stages is literature
review how to find literature how to
find data sets but dr kawar made a very
great
nice tutorial about that so we'll share
that with you once it's done
definitely thank you so much sir um
thank you so much for
um with that i would like to pass on
[Music]
over to you now thank you
uh so akansha can we have your
presentation now
akansha is one of her research fellows
from amity university and she is
pursuing a bachelor's in bad technology
over to you akansha you must share your
screen now thank you
thank you much uh is it visible to you
all
yes your screen is visible okay uh so
uh currently i'm working on uh
and since one month i'm like i joined
uh from last one month and um as you
introduced uh as soon as
i introduced i'm from america university
india
and uh so why did i choose uh
glioblastoma is most probably because uh
it has
most aggressive primary brain tumor and
it has like a high mortality rate
other than that it has a hindrance blood
brain barrier
which leads to failure of drugs to
target the glioblastoma
tissues and the real cause of
glioblastoma is still unknown to us
and the data set for the uh research i
chose is
uh from geo data sets and uh it has
uh three type sub sub types of samples
total samples are 118 and
it contains uh adult pure gastama
neurostem cells
and lower grade geoblastoma
other than that it has a metadata
kind of uh tissue types patient age
patient gender
idh status and based on idh status
i proceed my uh research questions
so my research questions uh are
basically uh
to like demonstrate the drug targets
based on the
uh differential expressed genes before
the
before that i
which uh status of glioblastoma and uh
how these genes vary in idh
y type and idh mutate mutated tumors
so the current workflow i am following
uh is
uh i have uh prepared my i pre
processed my uh uh samples into
uh normal stem cells glioblastoma cells
and
locate a lower grade glioma and further
i
uh perform scatter plot uh
on glioblastoma and normal stem cells
this is what i got results today uh
based on my uh pc one and pc two
uh result i perform scatter plot
so these are the normal uh normal
tissues and these are idh1 mutated type
and
uh blue one are the idh one wild type
so i still uh like i want to know
how to proceed further on after the
scatter plot
so this is all about
thank you so much akansha for sharing
your progress
and we would be looking forward to uh
more of your work
and uh dr harpreen do you want to add
something
yes uh thank you can you just go over
your pca plot
scatter plot please just care about
okay so here you have kind of uh we can
see i mean clearly see the difference
between
again if i'm just looking at the but
what are the blue samples
that are wild type id yes anytime
okay so again if you look at this wild
type sample you are like
still kind of three groups if i'm not
wrong
one is completely on the left side so
other one on the right side and
some of the samples are in between can
you just actually label these samples
exactly what are these samples similarly
based on the mutation
uh i mean mutated one i think the gray
one gray samples
and again there are like kind of
three groups but still i'm not showing
considering the third as a group
so can you label these samples further
with their other phenotypes
actually like what are the other
phenotypes in your data probably because
these are the
three different groups we need to
understand why they are like making a
three uh
different clusters
yes so basically like
already i mean you have maybe uh you
need to explore like what kind of
you know already meta data you have
maybe based on that you can label these
samples apart from these classes
okay uh i have no idea they are making
three different groups first
okay you mean i have to consider other
metadata as well
exactly just to understand first what
are these
uh three different groups right why it's
it's not making a single cluster
so probably there must be some other
phenotype
okay so you just need to explore your
metadata
and then just label your samples based
on different types of the metadata right
like here you just met i mean label your
sample based on this part
these three uh three phenotypes so you
must have other phenotypes just try to
do that as well
considering genes as as it is like
normal for example i'm just considering
normal male or female
so similarly maybe with the treated or
untreated some drug i mean
if you are considering wild type so that
is that is something that we need to
understand
before uh proceeding further
okay i'll look into it okay thank you
thank you and elia if you want to add
something
yeah so i would say again similar
response to every day so
you um a lot of times it's great to jump
into the data and see what's available
but you know take a look at the
literature uh
you know there is um a lot
that people have tried and so if we just
learn from our own mistakes we're
essentially going to be wasting a lot of
time because we're going to be trying
things and they might work they might
not work
you might have findings that seem
interesting to you but somebody
already did exactly that right so before
you
waste a lot of time use your time
to understand what has been done how it
has been done
it will give you also some ideas again
just even take a look at
what everybody presented today there are
some standard methods that everybody
will use
pca differential gene expression
you know there are other methods out
there and there are other questions out
there beyond
just what are the differentially
expressed genes these are popular
methods
you can try them they could be very
effective
but the overall design will be much more
interesting if you're more informed
what else could you do how can you do
this differently how can you not repeat
what somebody else did
that will also make your project stand
out
yes so i look into it i have actually a
less time because of my university
project
uh so i'm proceeding with this as of now
but i'll
uh definitely look for the other
questions as well
yeah which is absolutely fine but again
remember this is a research fellowship
program
you can do for your university whatever
your university requires but we
make this program available to those
that are interested in the research
question
you know if it's just an assignment
that's fine
you can treat it as an assignment for
these discussions
specifically these are places where we
discuss what you understand
in order to be asking questions that are
more interesting
more specific and uh are not just there
because somebody told you you know
these questions arise as a result of
something that
really spikes your interest so i think
you know that's just something that
is specific to this program there are
many other programs that we work on
there are more training programs
yes so
okay so i look into it
thank you and dr mohit for your
suggestions and thank you akasha for
sharing your progress with us
so for those who are a part of the lbr
and research fellowship
program we would be having a meeting
with you at 3 pm cst
and that would be in few hours and uh so
we have abukkar here from the lbrn group
i hope you have received the invitation
and you can meet uh
ilya there and share your queries
okay do you have any other questions
about a book card you can ask me in the
chat box
and i also wanted to introduce you all
our
upcoming program that is on precision
medicine it would be starting on july
6 and would end on august 5. it's a
month-long training program
and we have a free webinar to discuss
the role of bioinformatics and precision
medicine on 2nd of july
i invite you all to be a part of our
webinar there and learn more about how
bioinformatics could be used for
research in precision medicine
sector and i would be sharing the
program page with
a link with all of you as well here is
the link
you can go through it here we have
mentioned all the session details
and also what all would be covered on
what are dates and you can also go
through
the registration process for the same
now those who are a part of the research
fellowship program they would get the
access to our programs with 50
off on the program so that is what you
get at being a part of the research
leadership program
those who are interested may uh mail me
at marketing at the refine dot bio
and i would be there to assist you with
uh
things in a more further away and also
talking about the weekly this progress
report so we expect all our research
fellows to fill out this weekly progress
report and those who have
joined today we would be having another
batch meetings with you
and so what are these batch meetings we
have
weekly research fellowship meetings
where we discuss all the
uh president we have presentations by
our research fellows and we look at
their
uh progress who have almost completed
their projects or are on the verge of
doing so
but we take uh the progress report and
also help out each and every research
fellow
uh at different stages in their research
project in batch meeting so we have
divided our research
fellows in three batches and we would
have the badge three meeting scheduled
for tomorrow
and people who are a part of the lb rn
research fellowship meeting you
all would be having a meeting that is
scheduled on the
calendar and i've already sent out you
the invite so you would be updated by
that and also we would be soon up
loading our calendar on our portal so
that will stay updated
updated with everything and we expect
our
uh research fellows to fill out the
weekly progress report so that we know
about uh at what stage they are at
and if they are facing any sort of
issues and then we can help them
proceed further and also i would want
you all to please update your profiles
though many of you have already updated
but those who have not it's for them
please update your profile add a profile
picture to your account as if you're
already told and also link linking your
social accounts
so that it's easier for us to feature
your profile
uh with your performance on our social
platforms
and i was just having a word with
abukkar and he was asking me
how uh he proceeds for that also justice
ravi
ah you had few doubts about the research
fellowship program how it works so the
thing is that
uh in the first 15 to 20 days let's say
or
you can take a month as well to complete
the course material
and then you have to submit your
research proposal and in your research
proposal you have to address your
problem statement your project
stump up your project summary and link
for raw data and also the reference
publications
uh which you went through so ah in the
first
month you would have to go through the
asynchronous course material the project
samples we have to understand
how how the analysis could be done and
then go to
go through the literature part as well
and as elia told that we would be
helping you
uh with courses on how to review
literature in a more better way
right and then you come up with your own
research question you have to submit
your research
proposal form to us and then our mentors
would guide you
with the research proposal which you
submit it could be modified by our
mentors as well
to uh refine it in a much better way
your question uh could be refined at
each and every level but our mentors
would be there to
guide you from selecting your research
question
till completing it and i'm so sorry
yes so uh once you share i
feel you are entrusted to no further i
would be mailing you
all the details and then we can proceed
further with your enrollment
and uh does anyone have any doubts you
can put it in the chat box so that i can
answer it for you
and if not right now then you can mail
me at marketingbind.bio i already
shared my mela id and those who are
looking forward to apply to the research
fellowship program i'm also sharing the
link
of the research fellowship form with you
all you can proceed
further here
here is the link
okay thank you everyone for joining us
today uh we would be looking forward to
your
uh progress reports and uh let's
meet uh batch three members
tomorrow and discuss their report and
also we have changed the
uh time for the batch three members
because we
were noticing that many of you were not
able uh were not available at that time
period
so i've sent you out the invitation and
the
calendar has the time on it so uh be uh
please please stay uh please stay
updated thank you so much everyone for
joining
bye-bye thank you everyone
thank you
you